alright once again in life there was an
absurdly cool show that was cancelled
long before its time should have been up
and that causes people like me to get on
their cameras and tell you how cool it
was dollhouse right so dollhouse was
created by the creator of Firefly and
the director of the upcoming Avengers
movie Joss Whedon as you all know huge
fan of that guy this is one of the
reasons why so dollhouse came out around
2008 and it started a Liza Dushku and
from the ads all I knew is it showed
Eliza Dushku sleeping in this really
comfy place and walking around and what
looked like a utopia of a building and
then going out and kicking ass so you
guys if you saw that thought what I
thought you thought I said it's
Charlie's Angels secure that [ __ ] I'm
here to eliminate those theories this
show dollhouse is not like Charlie's
Angels you need to know that why because
the shows a lot cooler than Charlie's
Angels the concept is there's this
really huge organization called the
Rossum corporation it's kind of like
think the umbrella corporation for
Resident Evil is the Rossum corporation
in dollhouse they have an absurd amount
of money an absurd amount of tech what
they do is they take a person who
volunteers to be an active or a doll
they take that person's consciousness
and their mind and they put it onto a
hard drive now you just have the body
that has the most basic of mental
functions they don't have any will they
don't have any desire they're just
blocks of cheese with a pulse you can
kind of said they don't have a soul
while they're in their active state
while they're dolls and then someone
will call this company and be like oh
hey I need a person to be able to do
this for whatever reason and then the
brain tech guy in the show his name is
Topher he will construct a complete set
of memories with a complete personality
and then upload it onto the brain of
this doll and now this person is a
completely different human being they
can make people whatever they want and
they do this in the dollhouse
and these people get rented out for a
bunch of different reasons did your wife
die it's okay they can take Eliza Dushku
probably an upgrade and mentally
recreate your wife and then now you can
have her for like a weekend need someone
to do an assassination that's fine they
can make the perfect most efficient
assassin ever and they can go
assassinate someone bank robbery done
nothing point is they can make anyone
for any reason whatsoever as long as you
pay out what I liked about this is you
can tell Joss Whedon had so many
concepts in so many directions to take
this show that he never got to
alluded to some of them but never got to
do it before the show was canceled like
in one episode they kind of mentioned
the concept that for the right price
someone can just take their
consciousness and put it into someone
else's body and volt there you were an
80 year old with cancer now you're a
young 20 year old the person who owned
that body doesn't matter you paid five
hundred million bucks you can do
whatever you want really cool directions
a really cool moral dilemma with the
show what I liked about the show is
although it was a little episodic at
first you know Eliza Dushku just become
someone else and goes out and does a job
and comes back they used that concept to
set up a bigger story one of the bigger
stories is that there wasn't active his
name was alpha he freaked out one day
and just slashed up a bunch of people
and left but these actives these dolls
don't have any impulse or need or any
real cohesive thought so how did that
even happen there's this whole mental
evolution thing going on and the whole
concept of can you actually take
everything that makes a person what they
are and wipe it completely out or does
some of it remain and you get a cop that
is just looking into this he's like this
dollhouse is real no one knows if this
dollhouse is real
it's like Fight Club you don't talk
about Fight Club but certain people know
about it and this cop his name is Paul
Ballard he's like no this is human
slavery this can't happen a lot of other
people don't see it that way but that
really is what it is in season one alone
there are like three twists where I was
like dude that's awesome that is good
filmmaking or TV making it's the same
concept really Thank You Joss Whedon for
being smarter than people like me so I
can't think of this [ __ ] this is cool
and the coolest part the coolest part of
the entire thing is after season one
aired and we all were like oh yeah I
like dollhouse cool concept and alpha
and I like to see where they're going to
take the next season that's cool cool
cool cool cool at Comic Con
he showed everyone an episode called
epitaph one and it totally took a [ __ ]
on everything you thought you knew about
dollhouse in a very cool way the best
way really all right this is how I would
describe what epitaph one kinda was for
dollhouse imagine you buy a truck and
you're so happy with that truck you're
like this truck is so cool it's so
efficient I like it it's got some really
cool gear in it some really cool tech
glad I bought the truck and then you
find out one day that your truck is
actually Optimus Prime himself
that was what epitaph one was for
dollhouse it was the coolest thing in a
nutshell without any spoilers epitaph
one really kind of gave you glimpses as
to where the show was going and the end
game of the show and
you don't get intrigued by it I don't
even know it's a thank you Josh waiting
for being smarter than people like me
all in all the shows are really
interesting glimpse into human nature
that's what I would see dollhouse as by
the end is really interesting glimpse
into what technology does to
civilization and it's executed in a
really smart way I personally think
dollhouse was like the smartest show on
TV when it was out I'm telling you he
had some really sweet directions to go
and I'm glad that he got to show some of
them before the show was canceled it
almost felt like in season two it was
announced okay dollhouse is going to
come to an end Fox has cancelled it
because that's what Fox does they cancel
really cool [ __ ] and then the next five
episodes after that leading to the end
were just the coolest episodes ever you
can stream the show on Netflix right now
if you have Netflix the entire series
season 1 - epic afwan epitaph - the show
does come to a conclusion he was able to
wrap up his story which I like it's not
Charlie's Angels I promise whole lesson
of the entire show simply put one
sentence kids play with matches they
burn the house down so have you seen
dollhouse what did you think of it
comment below let me know if you haven't
seen dollhouse well I guess you got to
watch it so you can go ahead and comment
below and let me know and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]